[موسيقى]
المنتخب الالماني او الماكينات الالمانيه
جرت العاده يا احباب ان تكون المانيا احدى
الثوابت المرشحه للحصول على بطوله كاس
العالم بحكم تاريخها في المونديال او جوده
اللاعبين الالماني ولكن المفاجاه الكبرى
كانت خساره المانيا
امام منتخب الياباني في مونديال المفاجات
واعتقد واحده من الاسباب الرئيسيه تشتت
دهن اللاعبين الالمان خارج حدود المستطيل
الاخضر بقضايا ليس لها علاقه بالامور
الفنيه ولكن قضايا نفسيه والمباراه الاولى
دائما ما تكون مباراه نفسيه وانا سالت
اللاعب الهولندي الشهير الذي لعب اكثر من
بطولات عن المباراه الاولى في كاس العالم
فقال انها مباراه نفسيه في المقام الاول
لان اللاعب بيعي ان كل الجماهير تنتظر منك
المستوى وتتضر منك الظهور الاول والاداء
الاول وبالتالي هي مباراه نفسيه لذلك بعد
المباريات الاولى دائما ما يظهر مستوى
المنتخبات لكن المانيا ركزت على قضايا
خارج المستطيل الاخضر وهذا سبب تشتت
بالنسبه لها ولو شاهدنا المنتخب السعودي
عندما وجهت له رساله بان نستمتع بالمباراه
ولا نريد ممكن الانتصار خلقه اجازه امام
المنتخب الارجنتيني لانه يلعب بلاطه
[تصفيق]
المباراه القادمه امام المانيا ستكون
مباراه صعبه لان المنتخب الاسباني مستمتع
معدل لاعبي المنتخب الاسباني اقل من
اللاعبين الالمان وبالتالي قد تسبب صعوبه
للمنتخب الالماني قد نفهم قد نشهد مفاجات
امجد
المستحيل ليس المانيا فننتظر متعه باذن
الله تعالى في المنتج
[تصفيق]